hello it's our very first episode of
journey to the micro cosmos and to start
we thought some introductions were in
order
I'm Hank green I make youtube channels
including scishow and crash course and
this is James James is a scientist
living in Europe who has what I think is
the appropriate amount of enthusiasm for
microscopic life which is to say a lot
of it
James has active living colonies of
microorganisms throughout his home
though for clarity we all do he just has
them intentionally he keeps tardigrades
fed and happy gathers samples to search
out new organisms for his collection and
even takes samples in from elsewhere the
organisms we will explore on this
channel are going to be almost entirely
aquatic this makes them easier to care
for and to observe but in the world of
the micro aquatic environments might be
tiny droplets of water in soil on tree
bark or the thin film of water covering
the moss in your backyard organisms
featured on this channel will be
collected everywhere from soils to ponds
from puddles to seas these ecosystems
are similar to any you might find in the
macroscopic world in many ways tiny
organisms converting light into energy
like plants tiny organisms eating those
organisms and other tiny organisms
eating those organisms so on the African
savanna you will rarely see a zebra
consume a tree hole and then allow it to
continue photosynthesizing through its
transparent belly in order to produce
sustenance for them both
also you very rarely see a tree eat a
zebra in our world but as we will see
the micro cosmos can be a bit strange at
times James keeps what are called
cultures alive and thriving in his home
these cultures are whole ecosystems with
many
friend species living alongside each
other one is a monoculture of harmless
algae that we're living on blueberries
from the supermarket and will soon be
getting samples from one of the last
remaining untouched forests of Europe
and from the permafrost of Siberia
while this channel is going to explore
remarkable diversity we think it's
important to start out with the three
main sorts of organisms you're going to
see here first and most simple the
prokaryotes single-celled and lacking
organelles the ones you're most familiar
with are bacteria for hundreds of
millions maybe even billions of years
prokaryotes were the only life on our
planet and for clarity the earth is only
four-and-a-half billion years old the
main thing that distinguishes them from
the eukaryotes is that they don't have
membrane bound interior structures like
the nucleus or chloroplasts or
mitochondria but since they have been
around for so long
prokaryotes are remarkable in their
diversity they can be huge or tiny a
magnificent variety of shapes and colors
from green to red to purple
some contain mysterious crystals in
their cells some reproduced by being
broken into pieces a handy trait when
there are lots of things biting at you
and some of them can really move with
the aid of flagella long fibrous
proteins that extend through the cell
wall and wiggle around some bacteria are
the Cheetahs of the micro cosmos
[Music]
they tend to be tiny bacteria aren't
always easy to see even at 600 X
magnification though some can be
comparatively huge and that includes
cyanobacteria that around 2.5 billion
years ago were the first organisms to
evolve the ability to turn sunlight into
chemical energy that changed the game in
a lot of ways it was very good for many
organisms including eventually us and
very bad for many others but that's a
story for another day by one point seven
billion years ago the second sort of
organism you can expect to see here
arrived the eukaryotes now we don't want
to sound mean to our prokaryote friends
who are massively varied and complex and
wonderful but single-celled eukaryotes
take it to another level they tend to be
much larger and so we can get a better
view of their beauty and abilities
sometimes these organisms are even big
enough for us to see without microscopes
single-celled eukaryotes are often
sometimes called protists and we have to
make the single celled distinction here
because there are also multi cells
eukaryotes which include a lot of
different organisms including mushrooms
and trees and jellyfish and you but
since single-celled eukaryotes only have
one cell they can't have different cells
that do different things like we do
instead they have different areas of
their cells specialized they have
sensory systems they can feel mechanical
stimuli and react to it to avoid
predators the red spot in this protist
is an eye spot that has light sensing
structures beneath it they can hunt
actively or can avoid being eaten they
can build shells for themselves and form
colonies some even show simple learning
behaviors
the complexity of these single-celled
organisms sometimes makes you feel that
they have a consciousness and we're not
here to say that they don't
[Music]
some of the eukaryotes we show are going
to be photosynthetic like diatoms which
on their own generate twenty to fifty
percent of the oxygen produced on earth
and have cell walls made of glass the
best guess we have for how eukaryotic
cells formed is that a single-celled
prokaryote ate another prokaryote and
then found that life was better for both
of them if they survived together even
today the mitochondria in our bodies
hold their own separate DNA a relic of
that ancient event and finally the third
category of organism we'll be seeing a
lot of on this channel the micro animals
these are multi-celled eukaryotes just
like you and me
animals like Hydra which can
theoretically live forever
tardigrades that can survive the vacuum
of space rotifers that have thousands of
cells with specialized muscles
intestines even brains kinda so they are
in many ways like us but they also have
some traits that sound otherworldly
tardigrades are hatched with the exact
same number of cells in their body that
they will always have and these tiny
baby water bears then only grow as their
cells grow bigger and yet these animals
are so small that sometimes a
single-celled organism can swallow them
whole
sorry little rotifer it's important to
note that one cell can be a thousand
times smaller than another cell so a
rotifer can have thousands of cells but
still be dwarfed by one protist because
different magnifications are better for
observing different organisms we will
always have the magnification on screen
whether that's 10x 100x or as much as a
thousand times magnification so
prokaryotes the simplest organisms you
will see here no organelles but still
massively varied single-celled
eukaryotes or protists more varied more
specialized and micro animals
with thousands or even tens of thousands
of individual cells those are the three
main categories of the kinds of
organisms you can expect to see here if
you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss check out jams
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us that my friends is what
that subscribe button is for thank you
for coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us